[Musique]
je répète pierre michaud j'ai dix ans et
je plusieurs façons je suis très sportif
je pratique lors qu'ils de baseball le
football le basketball et le veulent ou
mentale parce que je ne suis pas avec
mes amis tout complot monté avec de la
lecture
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter un
procédé que peu de personnes connaissent
l'eau solide soit proposé un prometteur
pour les pays en voie de développement à
la nutrition
li parra qui nous disent zakeri moche et
légumes de devenir plus grand plus fort
et carys marché carottes soient me voir
moi sa mère tient plus cela pour fortis
et légumes ça peut coûter cher parce
qu'il faut que tu paies les graines
listeria siens et tracteurs acheter un
mais des trois qu'elle venait juste de
vous ne plus y en a qui ne devrait plus
coûter cher
savez vous sur lequel c'est le système d
irrigation à cause d'un nouveau procès
des quinze ingénieurs chimistes
mexicaine du nom de serge rico a éventé
lawson i love samedi mais oui mais le
zacharie l'eau c'est ça existe depuis
toujours c'est la glace mais j'aime pas
de la glace
c'est un gel plus près seulement du pôle
être là de potassium qui peut absorber
jusqu'à 500 fois sent poindre
j'ai sauté de vous parler de ça car ça
le plein bénéfice comme au mexique le
pays natal de son créateur
il ya beaucoup de sécheresse ils ne
peuvent donc pas faire pousser leurs
cultures tuera cette sécheresse
mais son intervention serait un moyen de
contourner ce problème ça les connaît
mais aussi beaucoup d'eau plus
précisément t 80 à 90% de l'eau co paris
à un système des relations normales avec
un système d'irrigation normal nous
avons besoin les 80 litres d'eau par
semaine et avec ceci
thème là nous n'avons besoin que de 50
litres d'eau par mois
c'est vraiment la différence énorme en
plus ça dure design n'est pas petit pour
le seul car ça se décomposent au fur et
à mesure croyez-le ou non
ça l'a fait de leur utilisation on peut
bien sûr faire pousser les plantes
on peut aussi la mettre à la base des
feux de forêt pour qu'elle s'installe en
progression ou même par des barrières de
dégel pour contrer l'avancée du désert
là vous devez vous dire avec
l'intervention ça nous coûtait très cher
mais non ça ne coûtait stx en dollars
canadiens pour 1,5 de 25 grammes et avec
un sac de 25 g nous pouvons guy un état
de culture amateur c'est un terrain de
soccer
higuain sergio rico déposé un brevet sur
son évasion
ce qui veut dire que personne n'a le
droit de le copie sous peine de
sanctions il a même déjà refusé
plusieurs demandes de rachat de brevets
pour pouvoir leur un accessible à toute
la population
je vais vous faire un exemple le jardin
de notre école qui mesure à peu près
d'esprit par d'esprit ça coûterait en
tout à l'école pendant pour irriguer
notre jardin pendant dix ans seulement
c'est ce petit de l'or je pourrais
qu'elle ment le pays pour qu'on aille se
prêtent ainsi mais malheureusement ce
n'est toujours pas disponible au canada
je me permet de croire que si quelqu'un
a inventé l'eau solide qu'un jour les
problèmes de sécheresse dans le monde
pourront pas être résolus
merci
[Applaudissements]